From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm just going to record a little brief announcement just for the table, so we have a record of that and then we'll just start talking.
Are you ready?
Ready.
Fantastic.
You're on.
Okay.
Today is October the 3rd, 2013. We're in Shreveport, Louisiana, and the beautiful sanctuary of the Mount Canaan Baptist Church with Reverend Dr. Harry Blake.
Good morning.
Good morning. Good to have you here.
Thank you so much.
Welcome to the hood.
Thank you. Thank you.
This is David Cline talking of the Virginia Louisiana Tech History Department and also working with the Southern Oral History Program at UNC Chapel Hill.
And we are here on behalf of the Civil Rights History Project of the National Museum of African American History and Culture of the Smithsonian and the Library of Congress.
Behind the camera today is John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
So again, thank you so much for being part of this project. We really appreciate your time and your willingness to be part of this.
It's really, it's extremely gratifying to have you here.
Thank you so much.
Where I'd like to start, if you would, is if you could just tell us a bit about your upbringing and where your people and where you came from.
And we'll try and tie that into a conversation about the work you've done on behalf of African American people in the Civil Rights Movement.
Good.
Oh, my parents, my daddy was born in Mississippi. My mother was born in Arkansas.
And I was born in Arkansas, but being the land of opportunity, the first opportunity my parents got.
They seized it and got me out of Arkansas and brought me to Louisiana.
Very, very young.
My background is that of a plantation. My daddy was a sharecropper who could not read a write.
I think my mother finished third grade.
So I was reared and lived on a plantation having been born in 1934.
I lived on a plantation till I was 24 years old, finished college. That was the year I finished college that I like to say I was liberated from the plantation.
My wife liberated me from the plantation.
Went to a one-room church school.
It was a public school. I guess you can describe it this way.
The plantation owner established your school in a church building for first through seventh grades.
And that teacher was not really a college graduate. She was a college sophomore.
She taught first through seventh grade, every subject.
So obviously it was not a lot she could do.
So I was almost a teenager before I learned to read and write.
I was promoted to junior high. I guess you would say eighth grade.
And that was my first encounter with the eight parts of speech and other things.
Because I was behind.
But I struggled to catch up.
And as a matter of fact, my whole life has been a life of trying to catch up.
And by the time I've caught up in this century, here comes technology.
And technology changes every week.
We all feel that.
This may not be meaningful.
I plowed mules. Here I am. Here I am in high school plowing mules.
And I decided for some unknown reason that I was not going to learn the language of the mule.
I was going to teach the mule my language.
And mule language was Whoa, gee, haw".
And I discovered that it was not in what you said to the mule that got his attention.
It was the pull of the reins.
So when I wanted the mule to stop, I just said stop.
And I pulled on the rains.
If I wanted to go right, I said to the right.
And I pulled on the right range.
So that's a humorous story, but it's true.
I did not learn mule language.
I had intelligent mules.
I taught them my language.
That's the humor of it.
Well, what lesson did you learn there with the mules?
How did you apply that later in life, if any way?
Let me add this.
My daddy taught me that there was a saying that you can lead a horse through the water, but you can't make him drink.
My daddy said, if you know how and put enough salt in his diet, he'll find water on his own.
I learned a powerful lesson from that in my pastoral ministry.
If I have a project, have a mission that the church does not see eye to eye, I sought the diet to make them first for what I'm trying to feed them.
So that has been very beneficial to me.
I learned also from this mule thing, if you know how, you can get people to do anything you want them to do.
I saw examples of that from Jim Jones and David Koresh.
They took lettered people, unlettered people, rich people, poor people, and met them to do whatever they wanted them to do.
Mr. Jim Jones even said to people, stand in line and drink poison, and they were anxious to do that.
So I think as a clergy person, you got to keep your motives right so you can lead people in the right direction.
Those were some leadership skills that I learned from the plantation and from life.
When were you called to the church?
That's my pastoral year in my pastoral days in the rural community.
I should just pause and ask you where exactly was the plantation.
I lived on two plantations.
One was in northeast Louisiana in Madison Parish, Tallulah, Louisiana, and the name of that plantation was the Ashley plantation.
Left there in 1951 and moved to Northwest Louisiana's Shreveport, Shreveport, and the plantation north of Shreveport was the Wood Spur plantation.
That's the plantation that I was liberated from. I went to college and after I finished college, moved to the city limits of Shreveport.
So my first passage was in 1958 in Shreveport, a one-sunday church.
That was the tradition of the rural areas churches did not meet every Sunday.
Some churches met every other Sunday, for instance, first and a third Sunday, or second and fourth Sunday.
So my first church was a one-sunday church, first Sunday.
And then I was called to a church closer to Shreveport, almost in the city limits.
It was a first Sunday evening and a third Sunday morning church.
I got called to that church, and then I got called just on the line of texts. It's called Bethany, Louisiana.
I got called to a second and fourth Sunday church. By 1967, 1966, I was able to turn those two rural churches full time.
To satisfy my conscience, I left both of those churches because I didn't want to go to one or the other and came to this church, which was 1966.
This church was in the most densely populated slum area of Shreveport called Allendale.
And I came here. Unfortunately, this church was not in a sense as advanced as my rural churches because we had air conditioning in the rural church and pews.
This church did not have air conditioning at the time. Now pews, we had benches and all that good stuff.
The building that I inherited was so dilapidated that I think a few years after I was here, it actually collapsed and fell in.
And this is the result of that building having been so dilapidated.
So I've been here since 1966, 47 years this year.
That's wonderful.
So let's talk a little bit about, let me ask you first, growing up on the two plantations.
What was it like for African American people in that time as far as opportunities available and as far as relationship with white people?
Let me respond to the last part of that question, relationship to white people.
This is interesting and a lot of people don't know this or may not agree.
White and Blacks, any confined narrow sense had great relationships.
For instance, if you were the white man's boy, you got whatever you need with certain restrictions.
I remember when the World War II, if you were a good worker on the plantation, you didn't get drafted to the military.
One reason is that the farmers were on the draft board of whatever it's called.
And if his Negro's name came up, got set aside.
I remember this expression. They would say at the end of the week when you got that day off, the go to town, the tea tell you, have a good time.
If you stay out of the cemetery, mean don't get killed, I'll keep you out of jail.
That meant you could kill another Negro.
You could do whatever you want just since you don't get into the white area. I'll get you out of jail.
That's the kind of relationship. White and Blacks, in a confined sense, got along very well.
I think, perhaps even today, my younger years would do anything for his Negro so long as he felt like he was handing it down to him, but not out to him.
Not on my, you will never be my equal. That's the way I describe the relationship.
And as you say, his Negro, so there's a sense of that.
You never forget you were mine. And the people who live on plantation were really his Negro.
And I'm using the language that was popular and they didn't Negro.
Because if you were a sharecropper, he provided a hut house for you to live in.
He provided the food for you to eat because he had what they call a commissary, a country store that he provided food and implements for farming and some clothing worklotings.
You got an advance on that. He would charge that to your account.
You had to use his muse to work the crop and his implements the plows and cultivators.
So he charged that to your account.
Now, let's say you were able to grow 20 bales of cotton.
10 of those bales belonged to the farm, their owner.
10 belonged to you and you paid the expenses for making those 20 bales out of your income.
And most of the time, at the end of the year, he would say to the plantation workers, you did good this year.
We broke even. Now you can't leave the plantation and go somewhere else.
You could leave the plantation if another farmer paid him to let you move to his plantation.
So you are always indebted. You owed your soul to the company store.
My daddy, fortunately, I don't know how he did it. I guess he must have found favor in the white owner.
He always, every year, would make a profit, maybe $200, not more than $500 a year.
And how we got from North East Louisiana to Northwest Louisiana, the manager,
followed the owner of the plantation, was offered a job in North Louisiana and he was allowed to bring as many of the Negroes from this plantation with him.
But he paid the owner. So we owed him. And you never got out of debt. You were always in debt.
And if I can sneak this in, America is pretty much on that style today because they keep us slaves with credit cards.
You asked me another question that I didn't address. I don't remember what he was.
Well, I asked about relations with white people. But just what it was like, I guess, within the black community as well at that time, how cohesive black communities were.
And I also want to ask about, if anyone was voting at that time.
No, no, no, no. No one was voting. The plantation that I lived on, when I became twenty years old, no black person was registered.
There might have been a handful of blacks in that part of Shreveport, Dixie, not Dixie.
Well, yeah, maybe Dixie, Belcher might have been a handful. How I got registered at, I believe the age limit then was twenty-one.
How I got registered, I gave an address of a friend of mine who lived in the city limits as my address.
And I studied the past test that was required in this state and in this parish.
So at twenty-one, though I was still on the plantation, I became a registered voter.
Now, do you remember what that process was, what the test was, and going through that experience?
Oh, yes, how well I remember. First requirement, in order to even apply, you had to have a registered voter to identify prove that you were who you said you were.
Now, if only whites are registered, what white person is going to vouch for you? There were few who would do that.
The other requirement was, you had to have identification, driver's license, or social security card.
And now you got to pass a test, what's the test? Interpret the Constitution, US Constitution, to the satisfactory of the voter register.
And Harvard Law, you couldn't do that.
Now, if you pass that, now you got to figure your age how old I am today in years, in months, and days.
And if you pass that test, they may give you a card.
That was true for Louisiana. In Texas, of course, you had to pay poll tax and all that kind of thing.
But it was just... No, it only takes a second.
So it was an incredibly difficult barrier to pass.
Incredibly difficult. Incredibly difficult.
And that was a part of my responsibility when I joined Martin Luther King's staff was to get...
to teach voter education, teach people how to pass the test, and to compute their age in terms of years, days, months, to the day that they were applying to get registered.
Now, speaking of Dr. King, of course, could you tell us the story of how you felt drawn to fight for civil rights, and how you met Dr. King and her organization, and began working with the Southern Christian Leadership Conference?
Though my daddy could not read it right, my daddy, as I think about it, was gifted in that he knew how to work the system.
Coming up in his era, he knew he had to pay homage to the white man. He'd call him Captain" and "Boss", and what have you.
But he knew how to get what he needed to survive. He said this to me one day. He said,
you can call a white man a dog if you know how and get by with it.
My daddy always did his teaching by demonstration. The boss bought a new car, and my daddy walked by the car and said,
this is a beautiful car. You know you are a big dog. Call him a dog. He liked it when he knew how to call him a dog.
I saw my daddy using techniques to get what he needed to get, but never diminished him his manhood. He never did that.
So my daddy taught me how to be a man and a proud man, even in the midst of segregation and on the plantation.
So I knew what I saw happening in America, particularly where I lived. Something was wrong with that.
And there became a burning inside of me and a yearning to see what I could do to change this.
I had a wonderful experience about life-grade. This is not on the plantation. This is in the little town of Dixie.
There were two stores in Dixie and a railroad station. I went to the summer of 52, maybe 51-52, to one of the store owners and said to him,
he would like to have a summer job. His name was H.L. Whitlow. He said to me, well boy I just hired two students, they were both college students, one white, one black,
and my brother-in-law is working for me this summer, and I don't need anybody. I wish you would come sooner.
Well as I was leaving the store, his wife said, hey boy come here, I'm going to talk to my husband about hiring you. I like you.
Well he said to me, well I really don't need you, but because my wife likes you, be here Monday morning and I'll try you out.
I was working on the plantation in the field and we would go chop cotton, pick cotton, we'd go to field at seven o'clock, get off at five, five days a week.
Well when I got to summer job at the H.L. Whitlow store, I had to be there for five, thirty in the morning because the field hands would stop in his store on their way to the field to get that by their lunch.
So I needed to be there during the rush hour. H.L. Whitlow was far ahead of his time as a white man. He practiced in the fifties equal employment opportunities.
He had a white student from Louisiana Tech working for him that summer and a black student from Grambling. However the white student worked in the store, but the black student was made in the house.
Well make a long story short. He told me, I'm going to try you out and if you don't ask me what I'm going to pay you, I'll pay you whatever you're worth.
Well at the end of the week he applauded me. He said, you could work. I like you and I want to keep you on.
Now on the plantation, five days a week, few hours per day less, I would make $15 a week.
Now I'm working six days at the store, started at five, thirty in the morning, get off at seven at night. And he said, I'm going to start you off with $15.
I said to him, I could work one day less and a few hours less and made $15.
And you did say you're going to pay me what I was worth. You said you liked my work. But if that's all you think I'm worth, I'm going to donate this week's work to you and give it to him.
He gave it back and he said to me, well what in the hell you think you're worth. That's what sir, you couldn't pay me what I'm worth but I wouldn't work for penny less than $25 a week.
And he counted out ten more dollars and my mom would say, chunked it at me, threw it at me. Well it was what I asked what I didn't write him throwing at me. I just got what I wanted.
Well the first thing that thing is for me was he took sick at the end of the summer. Now his college students are going back to school.
He sends his wife to my daddy's house and say, the school bus that Harry would catch at his house comes by the store.
Let Harry drive before he goes to school, your car and work and our full school and work after school and we'll make it worthwhile.
Well I'm part time in school and he pays me $25 a week. Now make some of, he can't pay me $25 a week.
And the next summer I was paid $40. When I finished high school I was making $300 a month and no black citizen in the rural was making that kind of money.
And my dad was a two most influential man in my life. He was called by his white friends a nigga lover because he believed in treating people fairly.
He made such an impression on my life that I still talk about him.
Do you think he ran a risk? Oh yes he did. He ran a risk. He did. But he was a Christian and he had money. And in America money talks.
So he could get away with it. Yes. So if you see that as a crucial part in your journey about how people treat one another and the rights and how to demand the rights, what would be the next step in that journey?
I remember this senior aged white farmer came to the store one day.
He was the postmaster. He was the host of his house in his store. And at lunch time he closed the post office and go and eat. And I was out sweeping the stoop of the store and this white gas saw me.
He said, hey boy. Is the post office open? He was asking me where the Whitlow had gone to lunch.
And I thought about how to think fast and quickly. Now I am a boy by age. But I'm not the kind of boy he's calling me.
And thirdly I'm not his boy. There's no law on the book that requires me to respond to him. Now if Whitlow called me a boy, he signs a check. He has a pay to call me boy. I'll answer to his boy.
And I didn't say anything. So he came over to me and touched me on my shoulder and said, hey boy. Is the post office open? I didn't say anything. He went in the store. Whitlow was there. He said, Whitlow, well you find that they're deaf and dumb nigga.
I laughed about that. He was so dumb. He didn't know that I wasn't deaf. I guess what I'm trying to say, I resisted to system in my way and got back with it.
And that was my early beginnings to kind of fight the system.
And as you say, your father was the model for that. He lost. He was the model. You asked me another question. I forgot to ask.
So what would be the next step then I guess in your journey?
The next step was I was very attentive to what was happening in Montgomery, Alabama. As a matter of fact, it may be 1950, 455 in Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
The Rev. T.J. Jemison had already staged a successful bus boycott.
One king knew about that and came to Baton Rouge to model the Montgomery boycott by what had happened in Baton Rouge.
Well, I watched and I read Martin Luther King Jr's book, Stride Toward Freedom and was impressed with him. It just so happened, I went to a small black church college in Marshall, Texas, Bishop College.
And Martin Luther King Jr was my commencement speaker.
The local civil rights leader here that I call, we call the father of the civil rights movement. Dr. C.O. Simkins was on Martin Luther King Jr's board of directors.
And he asked Martin to interview me when I graduated and hired me to work in Louisiana, Southern, Southern most area.
And in February of 1960, Martin invited me, Dr. King invited me to Atlanta to interview me and hired me on his staff. That was my first connection with him.
So that was February of 1960?
February of 1960, I started to work here in three board, March 1st. I was arrested first time, March 1st.
First day?
First day. It's interesting. I had taken a member downtown, they had a medical arts building where doctors, offices were. And I was sitting in my car waiting on them to come.
And a policeman on a motorcycle that came up and said, boy, you know what a jail house is?
And also I never been a jail, why would I know?
He summoned three to other policemen. They escorted me to the jail.
Ask, well, where's the chief? He's gone lunch.
What should we do with him? Take him up. And I guess they called it book and they handcuffed me. I mean, fingerprinted me and took my mother and all that.
And finally, the chief came.
They put me on the elevator with the chief and the chief took me to his office and said, you have a bright future in three board.
You just graduated from Bishop College and you're young. You got a role-church up there.
And I want to advise you not to ruin your future by fooling with the damn communist Martin Luther King Jr.
And he gave me this advice. And finally, he said, what are you going to do?
As soon as you release me, I'm going to go to work.
And I said, okay, lock him up. So what's here we're charging with?
Oh hell, charging with careless and reckless. So my first offense was careless and reckless driving and neither police officer had seen me drive.
And you were sitting in a park vehicle?
Yeah, in a park vehicle. And had been sitting there for 30 or more minutes before he came along.
I was arrested. I don't know how many times. I didn't see that as something to be clever or something.
I was one of four children. My dad had never went to jail and none of my siblings went to jail.
I am breaking that record. So I didn't keep up with it.
The most, the other most memorable arrest was the last time Dr. King was in Shreveport.
He is executive director Dr. Wyatt Tee Walker and I. He had this service where King was preaching.
The Ku Klux Klan protested the service so they were marching in front of the church.
And we went out and the young NAACP youth group were counter-protesting the Ku Klux Klan.
So Dr. Walker and I went out to see what was happening and the chief told us, go back into the church.
And Dr. Walker said, America is free. We can stand wherever we choose to stand.
And of course, I'm southern born, southern parade. Don't know that I would have said that.
And I made it a temple go back. He says, stay here harry-blank with me.
And they arrested us, put us in jail for mental observation.
We stayed there, I think, 36 hours. And many years afterward Dr. Walker invited me to his church in Harlem and he introduced me.
This is my friend, Harry Blake, when I was in Shreveport. We got arrested for mental observation, a charge for which he has not been cleared yet.
So what do you think they, I mean, brought that? What a bizarre charge, right? So why do you think they did that?
Well, they couldn't get anything else. And that way they could hold us. That was all about intimidation.
That was also all about seeing if they could dig in your background and find something, or could they create stuff to get.
And so the best thing they could create on me was that I was affiliated with the Communist.
Martin Luther King Jr and Dr. (Dr. C.O.) Simkins, who was here in Shreveport.
We were getting our orders and instructions from Moscow, because as Negroes, you were too dumb to think had to have somebody thank for you.
I came on the staff, March 1st, 1960, October 12th. There was an assassination attempt on my life.
I was driving from my rural church on a two-lane highway. And the car behind me, I thought, was pulling into the left lane, the park, to our pass.
And I heard this noise. I thought he had thrown a rock, but they had shot in my car.
And that the split second, the bullet came. I then followed to just my radio and the impact of the glass from the bullet to four holes in the coat I was wearing.
I pursued the car so I could get the tag number, reported to the sheriff, reported to the sheriff, and the sheriff said some days subsequent to that, that the owner of the car said he was he was bowling" at that time, so he couldn't have shot at me. And that's all that was done.
And that's how justice worked. That's how justice worked.
Don't know if I'm completing it.
Well, let me ask another question, because you said that Dr. Wyatt Tee Walker, what he said when he was standing out there, maybe not wasn't quite what you would have said.
And I just sort of want to ask about, there's the South, and there's how Wyatt's treated blacks and the South, far from universal.
So the question I want to ask is, did SEL, SEL, you sort of really knew what they were getting into in this part of Southwestern Louisiana?
Yes, yes. I'm assuming they did, because Alabama was equally banned Mississippi.
However, the Civil Rights Commission said in their report that Shreveport was the most difficult city in the South.
We didn't have the immaterial Medgar Evers, but we had what we had to keep Negroes on the control.
Because Shreveport was basically a plantation environment.
So those of us on plantation were disciplined mentally. There could be obedience.
So when he said to me to go back in church, I had seen what I needed to see, so I would have gone back.
But Dr. Walker from a different situation resisted, so I stood with him, and we both got locked up in jail.
Now, did you find support or any for support from your parents or from your church when you got involved?
Well, here's what I did. I went to my parents when I decided to accept Dr. King's invitation.
I went and said to my dad and mom, the job that I'm going to take may result in my death or injury.
But not only that, it may result in your injury or death because I'm your child.
I want to apologize for putting you in that position.
But you raised me and made me the kind of person I am.
And my dad said, I'd be disappointed if you did anything different.
And my siblings are younger than I.
They tell me now the kind of treatment that my dad had.
If the police was so him in a way, he'd stop calling him dumb.
You stupid ass nigga, and what have you.
And my daddy never responded when he got through with him.
He got back in his car and went on.
So he went through great humiliation because of me that he never shared with me.
And since you've ever had your dad's death.
Do you ever have the chance to talk with them and celebrate at all about some gains that were made?
I don't know if this answers your question.
When I helped my daddy to pass the voter test, that was a celebration that he got a chance
to vote in his lifetime.
The one thing that haunts me that I never did, it pains me so that I struggle to restrain
my tears.
I never taught my daddy to write his name, and I could have done that.
But he was a man of amoral self courage.
And jumping ahead again, I understand that you did run into some, quite some violence
yourself.
It's part of the movement if you wouldn't mind talking about that.
The girls who were killed in 16th Street Baptist Church bombing, President
Kennedy declared the next Sunday at day of morning.
The civil rights leaders suggested that we would have memorial services in our communities
that Sunday, September 22nd.
I went to our commission form of government then was a commission, a commission form of government.
I went to the commission of public safety to get a permit to have a march from Book of
Washington High School to the closest church, Little Union Baptist Church.
I think I went to the commission to the Tuesday, he said, I'll get back with you.
Saturday noon, he summoned me to his office and said, permit tonight.
Well, the next day, the service was going to be held in the morning and asked me, well,
what are you going to do?
As a well commissioner, you had five or six days to make your decision and you want me
to make mine in five or six minutes.
You'll see Sunday, well, I'm going to do it.
He said, well, let me tell you, anybody in street food participates in the march.
I will arrest every person participating.
Commissar you do what you have to do.
I knew he meant that.
I didn't want, if I can use this expression, innocent people participating in the march,
getting arrested, losing their jobs.
So here's what we did, no key.
We got the word out.
Me at the site where the march was to begin and they did, we told them, just go into the
church.
We can't see the march.
The commissioner was prepared and there were policemen, law enforcement people all over
this community.
Looked like by the thousands, they were on horses with bayonets and had garbage trucks
to haul the people that they were going to arrest.
It looked like there were literally thousands of black folk who showed up for the march.
But they didn't show up for the march.
They were amazed at what was happening.
So they came out of their houses on the streets looking and you may have scenes from that
if you don't.
We are sure them, which you said you can see it.
And at the close of the service, a lawyer, Dr. Tony Stone went to the commission and said
that's the commissioner.
We need to get out of the church.
He said, well, on the way you can get out, you come out two by two.
Well at that time, the white citizen group, Kluclaz Klan, were outside marching and protesting.
I went out of the vestibule to see what was going on the services over now.
And I met the commissioner and two other policemen in the vestibule.
And they'd manhandle me and began to beat me inside the vestibule of church, drug me
on the outside and every policeman who could get close enough to get a piece of my head
with his nice stick.
They thought I was dead or appeared to be lifeless and they left me late and on the lawn
on the sidewalk.
That was September 22nd, 1963.
And my wife was fearful.
My family was fearful of me getting medical attention from the white doctors through
me to Dallas.
And the young people at the high school decided something needed to be done and they began
protest movement.
And that's where the police beat them, tear gas, bombed them, went to the school, manhandle,
the principal hit and arrested a white teacher.
And the three-poort went into the greatest movement, I guess you could say protest movement
that had experienced during that week.
And of course, last two weeks ago we just finished the celebration of the 50th anniversary of Sept 22, 1963 Little Union beating.
Fifty years of that movement, yeah.
I mean that sounds like outright war at that point.
If you don't have access to the pictures, we'll let you sleep.
It looked like a war zone.
So how did that play out then in the coming months?
What about your own recovery?
I imagine that took some time.
Well, President of my school that was in Marshall had moved to Dallas, Texas, Bishop College.
And that president of the school put me in faculty housing until I recovered and came
back to report my wife and two children at that time.
So if you could just tell us about how the movement then went on starting with such a
movement on the violent beginning?
Well, here's the way I interpret it.
Remember I'm saying it was students.
Parents knew that Commissioner (George) D'Artois was a violent man.
And he had full control of the report.
He was the power.
He waifo feared him.
And black parents didn't want that children killed or hurt.
So they found a way to kind of quail that within a week or two.
And one way, one thing they did, they arrested students, there's a guy in this city who was
a student.
The commission of the society, he has to make somebody the leader as an example.
Decided he was the leader.
They put him in jail.
And I believe he tells that he stayed in jail, either 32 or 42 days.
He could not go to a school, public school in the city.
I think he moved to New Orleans.
But in any rate, 50th anniversary of Sept 22, 1963 Little Union beating later, they did grant him a high school diploma.
But he had finished school somewhere else in college.
So that's a part.
As a matter of fact, 40 years subsequent to the day that I was beaten, the city did,
and I'll show it to you on the wall, a public proclamation of apology for what had happened
to me.
Did you want to apologize?
I didn't want to be inhibited with my work here.
So I got called to this church in 66.
I went to the commissioner and said to him, Mr. Commissioner, I'm a new pastor in Shreveport.
I know what you did to me in Louis Union.
He said, let me stop you.
I didn't do anything.
I didn't touch you.
I said, we're not going to argue about that commissioner.
I want you to do me a favor.
I'm a new pastor.
There are things I want to get done in the Allendale community.
I'd like to have your support.
But before you pledge your support, I want you to know anything I've done in the future,
in the past, should I deem it necessary to repeat I will?
He said, well, you know, Reverend Blake, I have always agreed with your methods, but
I've always had respect for you.
What can I do for you?
And I went to the mayor and said the same thing to the mayor.
And the mayor said to me, Reverend Blake, I'm a politician.
Do you remember each time you were arrested?
What church you went before?
I said, church with my, he said that was my design.
I told them and told the church what he couldn't do to you.
I couldn't, I'm a politician.
I couldn't come out.
I know the movement was right and just, but I'm a politician.
What can I do for you?
I said, Mr. Mayor, anything I've done in the future, should I deem it necessary to repeat?
He said, I understand that.
What can I do for you?
And I showed him the condition of the church, but I also showed him the condition of this
community.
I went to an outdoor, operative, previous toilets in this community when I came to 66.
I want to build some housing for poor people.
And the city owns eight acres of land that's supposed to be a park, which has never been
developed.
I want you to give that to my church, to build housing.
He said the city can't sell property, but give me a little time.
He had an autonomous past that said property shall be sold to Mount Caenam Baptist Church
for $35,000.
And the use of the property is limited to housing, recreation, education, or religious purposes.
And we built 40 years ago a 120 unit housing for low income families and daycare center.
And then some 30 years ago, we built a high rise senior citizens tower next to that building,
a couple blocks away.
So that's what I started working on, helping to improve the community and helping with education,
which is my passion.
I just did it in a different way.
So if you could talk about how you see that kind of work, housing, senior citizen care,
education, childcare, being part and parcel of a movement.
It is a part of the movement.
Because people...
You see, the movement was targeted at the immoral things.
It was immoral for me to pay bus fare and have to stand in the back when they're
sitting in front.
It was immoral for me to go...
They didn't have Burger King's end, but similar places.
I have to go around to the window and pick up my hamburger.
It's immoral for a bus station to have a restroom and I can't go to it.
I can't drink out of it because it says white only.
That's one of the things the movement was focusing on.
I may be the only person in America who sees it this way.
I don't think Martin Luther King Jr, I know I didn't.
We were concerned about the kind of integration we got, particularly in school.
We weren't asking for them to integrate the schools necessary, necessarily, but give
the black school the same funding and the same capable teachers that you give to the white
school.
But the system in America is smart.
They took control and gave us a kind of integration that we weren't looking for.
Brushed us from our neighborhoods to the white schools and closed black schools and still
the black schools that were left still had inferior curriculum.
In the sense, I may be the only person in America.
In the sense, we got duped.
Now once you open up the hotels and the restaurants, if I don't have a decent income, I still
can't go there.
That's where I began to focus myself to get stores to hire blacks in places.
I like to tell this.
I was a cashier in the Whitlow store in the 50s.
I didn't go into Seagal Box to make change.
I went into cashier and stuff.
I was a cashier in the country 10, 15 years before we got a black cashier in the city.
That's why I keep going back to Whitlow.
He helped me do stuff that even the city's street would not do it.
How are your relations now with some of these people that you went through all of this
against or with?
Obviously, the Whitlow guy, he was 60 years old in the 50s.
He's gone to heaven.
Have good relationship with white.
Have good relationship.
I have no interest in Seagal.
I won't say I don't have an interest in politics.
I have no interest in being a politician, holding position.
Don't let it all.
But I do want to determine who gets the position.
I would never want to be a mayor because if you are mayor, you are one or two term mayor.
But if you make mayor, you are mayor every time you make one.
That's my position.
Guess I answered your question.
Yes, it does lead me to another one.
Where has the source of black power and the church in the church or elsewhere?
Another way of asking that is who have been your allies as you have worked on these issues?
I think if you ask other citizens, you get different responses.
And as I see it, the power has been in the black church and still is because every Sunday
morning you get a captive audience and you can kind of mold and make in your area your
church, your community, what you want to see happen in the salt, salt the diet.
Yes, exactly, exactly.
We will salt the diet.
When Martin Luther King Jr first came to Shreveville, during those years, blacks were fearful of his
presence.
Because on that he died that everybody, for the most part, saw him as the prophet.
There were several churches who voted that he could not preach.
As a matter of fact, this church was vacant in the height of the civil rights movement during
the 1961.
My name came up as a candidate and they voted.
Harry Blake is a good man, he's a good leader, but he made it out, church bomb got burned.
And they didn't realize that was a blessing with the condition that church built.
It was only after the civil rights movement had taken a different direction that they considered
to call me.
This has been wonderful and let's start to wrap up.
So what are you focusing on now?
Focusing at going home sitting there.
I'll be 80 years old next year.
My focus now is all over America.
All over America and it cannot be denied that the school system needs help.
In trouble.
And unfortunately for me, I've always tackled what appeared to be impossible.
When I read statistics that the system decides by the time a Blake boy becomes fourth grade
depending on how he's performing, they determine how many prison cells to be by fourth grade
students.
Like males in America, I am trouble.
So it is my, it is incumbent upon me to have a ministry in my church to develop strong,
moral black men.
That's where I'm going.
What do you do with the fourth grade, third and fourth grade boys?
Teach them how to read.
Do you start a school and compete with the public school?
I'm not sure that I want to do that.
So three summers ago, I started a summer boy as a academy.
I remember, I think we've had up to 50 in that.
One boy was on second grade reading level and when we got through with him, he was on
sixth grade reading level.
So I know it can be done.
There's a boy in this church named Walter, 12 years old.
And I kept hearing that he came read, he came past fourth grade material.
I said to my church, we got a had Walter".
And perhaps you didn't have said this.
But I said, if this was a white church, we'd find a way to help Walter.
And this church, this church is so academy, they allow me to try anything that just
can help people and they underwrite it.
I said, out of my first church, let's homeschool it.
And somebody in the background said, homeschooling in your house, not mine.
So that caught on.
And I did some investigation.
There's virtual school.
That's a term that I didn't know about.
And finally, there's a young woman in this church who sympathized with my passion.
I said, pastor, I've been teaching in the system, the other parish.
I think she said for 33 or 35 years, I hadn't planned the retire this year, but I will retire.
And that was in July.
I will turn my papers in next week to come over here and help you with that school.
And I'd like for you to see her before you leave.
Just me and she see it.
And we have five boys in that school.
And we'll take some more next year.
And they come every day?
Every day?
From eight to three.
So you are homeschooling in the church?
Homechooling in the church.
And the church allows me to do that.
That's what's so great about Mount Canaan church.
They allow me to do silly, not silly, crazy stuff.
And I generally make it work.
We generally make it work.
That's interesting.
Even in the movement, which was a mass movement, it was about one-on-one change in interaction.
And here's an example of intervention at a personal level.
Well, anything that we didn't cover that you want to add, I'm sure there's a lot.
Oh, I need more to do this.
I'm so glad you did.
I'm not really.
You never thank my secretary.
Daddy, you got to do it.
For posterity.
I won't be here for posterity.
I really wish I could think of something else that I'd be to say.
Other than Mount Canaan church is right in the center of the hood.
But making a difference in the hood, and they give me full range to bring about change.
Best thing happened to me was this church in the hood.
John, did you have anything you wanted to ask?
I want to thank you.
Every question I got on the tip of my tongue is already in.
Fantastic.
Well, thank you so much.
I can't even express how much I appreciate it.
I do want you just to see this teacher.
Absolutely.
And I know some of the pictures that you were talking about, too.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.